[Musique]
je vous le dis vous appris c'est la
tendance
ah oui ça va la tendance est là avec les
attentes au matin quand je me réveille
c'est l'euro vous êtes à l'antenne et
l'autre jour madame dit hayat on a mille
indiens qui a diffusé sa chance et
s'approche à l'occasion de te voir aussi
en dehors
à chaque fois c'est un kiff y a pas
d'histoire foulée d'un fois c'est quand
je t'ai vu même quand il mange il est
propre
c'est très tendu nous on était à obtenir
la vérité on a mangé avec toi il y avait
ma dit m talât et moi on était ça la vie
du chocolat sur les toits que la c2 et
mme hillary ils mangent dans une salle
où je suis arrivé avec soraya unis
charia c'est pas que j'aime bien euro
suivra mais j'trouve que je bouge pas
c'est en ce moment à je bouge pas c'est
en ce moment ce ca ou stagnent ou stagne
au niveau capillaire
donc je vais dit il faut que tu m'as
faut qu'on aille plus loin donc avec une
solution à la non si c'était
la rate c'est indispensable
bah c'est un petit peu comme vous dans
l'émission
j'ai pas s'ils ont gagné la guerre
d'héritage mais ce que je sais c'est
qu'elle a enfin goûté les gens qui lui
conseillaient la modération et d'être
d'écouter les les bonzes les vrais amis
c'est dieu qui aime le jeu cap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je savais quelle beauté wenn man ce
qu'il a fait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
vu mais c'est vraiment c'est un des
types les plus beaux tox de ma vie on
analyse médias ton esclave
alors moi c'est bien jean soins des
crèmes anti rides est la leur à répondu
non vous emmerdez pas c'est déjà trop
tard
c'est pas une histoire à nous n'avons
pas là il est ajouté mathieu daris à
hamouna
plus sexy qu'un chameau de djerba alsace
vis à vis toujours comme thala
allégée du 9 3 boing boing comme ça
c'est vraiment idiot in swing bad gones
seraient radiées va te faire [ __ ]
tu as gagné je suis qu'un faux coup
j'ai eu des problèmes avec sa belle
doche mais name nom soit arrêté beinheim
a et b nay ne savez jamais de problème
est que personne vous avez jamais trompé
personne
vous avez jamais montjuic voulait qu'à
paris non non c'est bon pas à lysekil
faisant serré vous n'en serez plus moi
j'ai lu effectivement elle dit que tout
est positive
au départ on verra comment le prendre à
son licenciement
c'est ce qu'ont bien la galère poitrine
a touché par poste et nous agace ouais
c'est ça c'est entre cat et 6000 euros
par mois et pourquoi vous venez dans
l'émission l'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
rethel
était ce jour rien n'est parfait
[Musique]